der 27 spieltag beginnt an der castroper
straße in bochum und endet mit einem
eklat die partie zwischen dem vfl bochum
und borussia mönchengladbach wird ein
nachspiel haben zwar treffen zunächst
player und symbole für die fohlen elf
doch in dieser partie ist das höchstens
eine randnotiz schiedsrichter assistent
christian kittl man wird in der 69
minute von einem bierbecher getroffen
der unparteiische benjamin cortus
unterbricht das spiel dann der abbruch
in diesem fall bei seinem angriff beim
tätlichen angriff auf einem
spieloffiziellen gegen den
schiedsrichter assistenten ist ein
spielabbruch einfach alternativlos zum
achten mal kommt es in der bundesliga zu
einem spielabbruch der für den vfl
bochum konsequenzen haben wird
nach zuletzt zwei unentschieden in der
liga geht es für den fc bayern münchen
gegen union um zwei dinge dortmund
weiter auf distanz zu halten und auch
darum mal wieder mehr als nur ein tor
pro spiel zu erzielen kingsley command
in der 16 minute zum 1 0 für den
rekordmeister
minute im union-tor allerdings nicht
ohne abwehrchance die gäste aus der
hauptstadt im ersten durchgang durchaus
ebenbürtig doch die bayern eiskalt zu
zum 20 in der 25 minute
kurz vor der pause minute gegen
lewandowski schiedsrichter osmers gibt
elfmeter der rest ist lewandowski 13 0
für die bayern für lewandowski ist es
saisontreffer nummer 30 zum fünften mal
erreicht der pole die 30 tore marke in
der liga kurz nach der pause bayerische
leichtigkeit und ines müller musealer
lewandowski zum 4 0 endstand
der rekordmeister siegte souverän jedoch
ohne den ganz groß den glanz gegen
fischers köpenicker
manuel neuer freut sich über einen
historischen bestwert es ist sein 311
dreier niemand feierte mehr siege in der
bundesliga
torjäger unter sich köln empfängt
dortmund der bvb nach zwei monaten
wieder mit erling holland in der
startformation ist es jedoch nicht der
norweger sondern seine frisur zwillingen
marius wolf der die borussia in der 8
minute in führung bringt das dritte
saisontor für den ex kölner wolf und der
rückkehrer
holland in der 25 minute noch nicht so
wie man es von ihm gewohnt ist in einem
insgesamt hochklassigen spiel gelingt
köln neun minuten vor der pause der
verdiente ausgleich sebastian andersen
zum eins zu eins modell ist verlängert
per kopf andersons dritter saisontreffer
zuletzt im november
50.000 in köln sind ein spiel der
leidenschaft tillmanns rettungskräfte
gegen renault sinnbildlich eins zu eins
heißt es am ende zwischen dem fc und der
borussia dortmund damit sechs punkte
hinter dem fc bayern
wie in allen stadien an diesem spieltag
wird auch in wolfsburg vor der partie
gegen leverkusen dem verstorbenen ex dfb
präsidenten egidius braun gedacht
wolfsburg ist gegen bayer über weite
strecken die aktivere mannschaft doch
leverkusen ist das team das am ende
triumphiert der eingewechselte paulinho
entscheidet später spiel zugunsten der
werkself der brasilianer nach seinem
sololauf in der 86 minute zum 1 0
johannis joker sticht auch in der
nachspielzeit paulinho zum 2 0 endstand
bayer leverkusen unterstreicht in
wolfsburg spät aber eindrücklich seine
champions-league-ambitionen
[Applaus]
r b empfängt frankfurts die discos
leipziger auf der erfolgsspur richtung
champions league die sachsen bereits mit
sieben siegen in der rückrunde in der
gesamten hinserie waren es nur 6 leipzig
überzeugt über weite strecken gegen die
eintracht lässt aber insgesamt zu viele
chancen liegen trapp lenkt sie max
distanzschuss mit der ersten hälfte an
den pfosten auch in der 41 minute steht
leichtmetall der führung der sachsen im
wege leimer an die latte
frankfurt kann sich am ende bei seinem
torhüter bedanken der an diesem spieltag
die null fest reimers versuch in der 62
minute eine von vielen ungenutzten
gelegenheiten r&b und eintracht trennen
sich 0 zu 0 torlos
mainz jubelt früh gegen bielefeld nach
nicht mal 30 sekunden erzielt jonathan
burkert das 1 0 für die rheinhessen das
kuriosum des spieltages in der 15 minute
schiedsrichter zweier bekommt ein signal
das hawk eye das vermeintliche 2 0 für
mainz wird überprüft und niag at store
zurückgenommen ein fehler der
torlinientechnologie den das
schiedsrichtergespann korrigiert in der
zweiten hälfte fand sogar die zellen
drei mainzer werden elfmeterwürdig
gefällt barreiro zunächst von titel
strafstoß mehr kt zum 2 0 für die
nullfünfer andrade ford barreiro wieder
elfmeter jonathan burkhard tritt an und
verwandelt eiskalt zum 13 0 für mainz
und der dritte fall gleich hinterher
wieder titel irgendwann zum feld der
gefoulte macht es selbst zum 4 0
endstand 3 meter in einem
bundesliga-spiel für eine mannschaft das
hat er es zuletzt vor zehn jahren
gegeben bielefeld verliert zum vierten
mal nacheinander und rutschte auf einen
abstiegsplatz
party in der hauptstadt ohne felix
magath auf der bank der neu trainer der
hertha verpasste das spiel gegen
hoffenheim wegen einer krone infektion
auch aus der distanz scheint magath den
krisengeplagten hauptstadtklub zu
beflügeln stark per kopf zum 1 0 für
berlin der treffer wird wegen einer
möglichen abseitsstellung überprüft und
10 nach dem seitenwechsel führen wieder
standards zu toren plattenhardt kämpft
belleville 20 hertha auch der 13 0
entstand fällt nach einem ruhenden ball
plattenhardt hereingabe und tue sagt der
torschütze marco verringern magaths
vertreter auf der bank und die hertha
bayern gegen hoffenheim den ersten sieg
im jahr 2022 und drei wichtige punkte
im kampf gegen den abstieg
wird gegen freiburg abstiegsangst trifft
auf champions league hoffnung dass es in
diesem spiel am ende keinen sieger gibt
hat gründe streichs freiburger scheitern
mehrfach am aluminium zunächst am
pfosten und haberer im zweiten durchgang
an der latte in einer intensiven partie
es führt nicht ohne chance ebelings
hacken teams und thermen schuss von
flecken pariert am ende heißt es 0 0
zwischen dem kleeblatt und dem sportclub
ein ergebnis das keinem der beiden teams
entscheidend weiterhilft
das schwäbische duell zwischen stuttgart
und augsburg steht unter dem titel
abstiegsangst die gäste gehen mit ihrem
torschuss durch jahren nach lagos vorbei
10 führung doch der vfb zeigt in diesem
abstiegsduell mehrfach moral und
comeback-qualitäten freistoß kopfball
anton zum eins zu eins in der
nachspielzeit des ersten durchgangs
erzählt gregor iec das 2 1 für die gäste
und stuttgart ist wieder im
hintertreffen
nach dem seitenwechsel der vfb
allerdings hellwach namens gefühlvoll
zum 2 2 in der schlussphase besorgte
thomas den 13 2 endstand pellegrino
matratze dank mittendrin im stuttgarter
jubel kollektiv drei wichtige punkte
gegen die abstiegssorgen
die ergebnisse des 27 spieltags im
überblick bayern gewinnt 14 0 gegen
union dortmund nur eins zu eins in köln
carter und stuttgart feiern wichtige
siege in sachen klassenerhalt keine tore
in leipzig und entführt spieler bruch in
buchung in der tabelle baute der fc
bayern nach dortmund unentschieden die
führung auf sechs punkte aus leverkusen
und leipzig auf kurs champions league
viel bewegung am tabellenende bielefeld
steht nun auf einem abstiegsplatz
stuttgart klettert härter auf dem
relegationsrang
[Musik]